>>> SEEMS LIKE IT HASN'T BEEN A
QUIET DAY AT TWITTER SINCE ELON
MUSK TOOK CONTROL.
TODAY THE ACCOUNT THAT TRACKED
MUSK'S PRIVATE JET HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED.
IT'S A STRANGE STORY THAT HAS
BEEN TAKING A LOT OF TURNS
TODAY.
FIRST THE BACK STORY FROM DONIE
O'SULLIVAN.
>> I'M JACK SWEENEY, AND I'M A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CENTRAL FLORIDA.
>> THE DATA I RECEIVE IS THE
IDENTIFIER, THE ALTITUDE,
LATITUDE, LONGITUDE.
>> Reporter: JACK SWEENEY SET UP
ELON BOT, ALL USING PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
>> WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO SET UP
THIS ACCOUNT?
>> I WAS A FAN OF ELON.
HE DOES SOME PRETTY COOL STUFF
WITH SPACEX AND TWITTER.
IT GIVES YOU ANOTHER VIEW THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
WHERE THAT PERSON'S GOING AND
MIGHT GIVE YOU CLUES INTO WHAT
NEW BUSINESS IS GOING ON.
>> THE ACCOUNT TRACKED UP MORE
THAN A HALF A MILLION FOLLOWERS.
JACK SAYS LAST YEAR, THE
BILLIONAIRE ASKED HIM TO SHUT
DOWN IT DOWN.
>> I WAS ABOUT TO GO TO SLEEP.
I REMEMBER TELLING MY ROOMMATE,
HEY, ELON MUSK JUST DIRECT
MESSAGED ME.
>> WHAT DID THE MESSAGE SAY?
>> IT SAID, CAN YOU TAKE THIS
DOWN?
IT'S A SECURITY RISK.
>> Reporter: IT SHOWED THE
BILLIONAIRE WAS CURIOUS, EVEN
IMPRESSED, WITH JACK'S CODING
SKILLS, ASKING, HOW ARE YOU ABLE
TO TRACK USING A BOT?
>> I DIDN'T REALLY FEEL LIKE
TAKING IT DOWN BECAUSE IT MEANT
A LOT TO ME AND IT STILL DOES.
>> Reporter: ELON SAID, I DO NOT
LIKE THE IDEA OF BEING SHOT BY A
NUT CASE AND OFFERED JACK $5,000
TO SHUT IT DOWN.
>> I ASKED FOR $50,000 OR A
TESLA, AND SAID THINKING ABOUT
IT.
>> Reporter: MUSK DIDN'T TAKE
HIM UP ON THE OFFER.
SOON AFTER ELON BOUGHT TWITTER,
HE TWEETED, MY COMMITMENT TO
FREE SPEECH EXTENDS EVEN TO THE
ACCOUNT FOLLOWING MY PLANE.
HE TWEETED THAT ABOUT A MONTH
AGO.
CLEARLY HE DOESN'T FEEL THAT WAY
ANYMORE.
>> YEAH, IT'S COMPLETE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT HE SAID.
>> Reporter: ON WEDNESDAY
MORNING, JACK WOKE UP TO NEWS
THAT HIS ELON JET ACCOUNT HAD
BEEN SUSPENDED FROM TWITTER.
AND IN THE AFTERNOON, TWITTER
SHUT DOWN HIS PERSONAL ACCOUNT.
>> I LITERALLY HAD JUST TALKED
ABOUT HOW THE ACCOUNT IS THE
CANARY IN THE COAL MINE.
IT SHOWS HE CAN CONTINUE TO DO
THE WHAT THE LAST PEOPLE AT
TWITTER DID AND THEY CAN BEND
THE RULES HOWEVER WAY THEY WANT
FOR WHOEVER THEY WANT.
>> Reporter: ELON HAS HIS
BILLIONS, BUT JACK HAS HIS
GRANDMOTHER PHYLLIS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF YOUR
GRANDSON GOING UP AGAINST THE
WORLD'S RICHEST MAN?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE I'M A GRAND MA, KIND OF
SCARY.
>> YOU GOT A GENIUS ON YOUR HAND
THERE IS?
>> EVEN WHEN HE WAS TWO, HE WAS
A GENIUS.
HE WAS ALWAYS INTERESTED IN
GOING IN THE GARAGE, AND IF
ANYTHING WAS BROKE, HE WAS THERE
TO FIX IT, PUT IT TOGETHER.
AND HE COULD FIGURE IT OUT.
>> Reporter: JACK SAYS HE STILL
ADMIRES MUSK.
IF ELON SAID, COME WORK FOR ME
AT TESLA OR TWITTER, WOULD YOU
TAKE THE JOB?
>> OH, YEAH, FOR SURE.
>> IF ELON MUSK IS WATCHING
THIS, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO
HIM?
>> HE BETTER NOT FORGET THAT I'M
HIS GRAND MA.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE GOT TO SAY.
>> I LOVE HER.
>> I HEARD HER IN THE BACKGROUND
OF THE INTERVIEW, AND I WAS
LIKE, JUST BRING HER IN.
>> THAT IS A VERY GOOD INTERVIEW
MOVE.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON ALL THIS?
>> SO, LOOK, WE HAVE SINCE
LEARNED ACTUALLY IS THAT MUSS
SKPK TWITTER CHANGED TWITTER'S
POLICY OVER THE PAST 24 HOURS TO
MAKE THE CONDITIONS SUCH THAT
THIS ACCOUNT GOES AGAINST THOSE
POLICIES SO IT COULD BE
SUSPENDED.
AND, LOOK, I MEAN --
>> SO, IT'S A NEW POLICY IF IT'S
A SECURITY RISK FOR BILLIONAIRES
WHO HAVE A PRIVATE JET?
>> ESSENTIALLY.
IF I HAD A PRIVATE JET, I
WOULDN'T LIKE TO BE TRACKED IN
REAL TIME EITHER.
AND THERE ARE, OF COURSE, SOME
REAL CONCERNS OF HIS SAFETY, HIS
FAMILY'S SAFETY.
>> SURE.
>> BUT FOR THIS FREE SPEECH
ABSOLUTIST, AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT SPEECH THAT MIGHT CAUSE
HARM, WE'VE SEEN HIM THE PAST
FEW WEEKS TEAR UP THE RULEBOOK
AGAINST COVID MISINFORMATION AND
VACCINE MISINFORMATION ON THE
PLATFORM, BUT WE'VE SEEN HIM
REPLATFORM A NEO-NAZI AND WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
FOR THIS TO BE THE ISSUE, FOR
THIS TO BE THE SPEECH --